-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#VacationFail tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
Kalliefornia.
I get it.
She says,
"We went to Myrtle Beach
and put my dad in charge
of taking the pictures.
When we got them developed
all the pictures
were of my dad's eye.
[ Laughing ]
[ Applause ]
"How do you use this thing?"
It was the best trip ever.
This one's from @stacynovels
She says, "My friend
has a prosthetic leg.
As a kid, her dad would
run out of the ocean with it
screaming 'shark attack.'"
[ Laughing ]
Not cool.
That's not cool, man.
-Or is it?
-Yeah, it might be cool.
This one's from @cheermomma84.
She says, "My dad and brothe
left us in the tent
to investigate
because they heard a bear.
Turns out it was
just my mom snoring."
[ Laughing ]
She's not a bear.
This one's from @cuttsmarissa.
She says, "My dad got
dragged out by a riptide
and waved for
my mom to save him.
She stood on the beach
waving back."
"Hi, honey!
You're doing great!
You're doing great!"
This one's from @moniefry.
She says, "Our vacation rental
had this picture hanging
in the living room.
We had to hide it in the close
because it scared us all."
Look at the --
[ Laughing ]
-Wait, wait.
Wait, what is it?
-I gotta see it again.
I gotta see it again.
-Oh, my God.
-Is he holding baby bottles?
-I think he's holding
baby bottles with like a..
zucchini -- no,
an eggplant on his head,
a glass of milk.
Oh, that's another giant bottle.
-It's another bottle.
-Yeah, that's fascinating.
I think I just saw
its eyes move.
This one's from @livvierosee
She says,
"My dad accidentally bough
women's capri pants
at Disney World
and got mad at us
when we told him."
[ Laughing ]
They accentuate my thighs.
-Slim cut.
-This one's from @LytleSarah
She says, "In New York City,
my aunt said,
with all sincerity,
'The Statue of Liberty's
arm is up.
That means the president
is in town.'"
[ Laughing ]
-[ Imitates
mechanical whirring ]
[ Singing "Hail to the Chief"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I never knew it did that.
-I didn't know. I had no idea.
-This one's from
@schwabbie1022.
She says, "On vacation,
the waiter brought over
flaming shots.
My dad made a toast,
and his hair caught on fire.
"To the paramedics."
This one's from @tress98.
She said, "We missed our flight,
so my parents made us
take pictures
in front of
a tropical-themed poster
so it looked like we went.
-Yeah! That's thinking!
-That's a good idea!
-That's thinking!
-This one is from @brianlub --
lubbin? No, lubing.
Brian Lube?
-Brian lovely lubin'?
-Brian lub-lub...lubin?
-Brian loves lubin'.
-L-U-B...
-Get some lovin' in the oven
-It's not -- it's not --
it's not Brian loves lubin'.
I think L-U-B-A-N
is his last name.
Anyway.
-Here's a tweet from this dude
-I appreciate
the tweet from him, yeah.
I don't have to
hang out with him.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I'm sure he's a great guy.
-He says, "My mom said she'd
ride Space Mountain with m
because I was scared.
When we got to the front,
she said, 'Nope!' and left
I rode with strangers."
Thanks, Mom!
Those were our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite,
#WorstRoadTripEver tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's
from @johnnycantrock,
He says, "Got lost
on the way to Disneyland
because instead of
following the road signs,
my dad just followed a bus
with the Disneyland ad on it."
[ Laughing ]
-Come on, dad.
-"Kids, pose by the bus.
Let me get a picture with you.
We're at a bus depot.
-Alright."
-"There we go. Let's go home."
-"I guess Mickey's sick,
you guys."
This one's from BECCAnoH.
She says, "We were stuck
in traffic for so long,
only one side of my face
got sunburned.
I looked like a Batman villain."
This one's from @JLaufe.
She says, "My dad got
so fed up with our fightin
that he pulled over
and laid down
in the middle
of an empty highway."
You finally broke him.
You broke him.
He's a broken man.
I don't care anymore.
-"Take me, Lord!"
-You broke dad.
This one's from @masonclashes.
He says, "My older brother
wired my friend's car brakes
to the horn so that whenever
he braked, the horn honks.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, this is a good one.
This one's from @klaracee91.
She says, "We got detained
at the Canadian border
because my brother
answered 'not really'
when asked if he had
weapons in the car."
What?
"Not really."
What does that mean?
This one's from @AndrwWard
He says, "Dad drove throug
a paper mill town,
cranked down the windows,
and yelled,
'Breathe it in, boys,
that's what money smells like!'"
-Is he a paper magnate?
-I don't know.
This one's from @AmyTucker26
She says,
"My parents let my brother
buy a harmonica
at Cracker Barrel
on the very first leg
of a weeklong trip."
I could just imagine
how annoying that would be
[ Imitating harmonica ]
This one's from @BelleofBabble
She says, "My friend's crapp
car had no working blinkers,
so I had to hang out the windo
with the toy lightsaber
to indicate our turns."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Someone's landing a plane
in front of us!
-This last one's from evanaye.
He says, "Our stuff fell off
the roof, so people honked
My dad didn't know
why they were honking,
so he flipped off
every car that had honked.
There you go! Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
tonightshow.com/hashtags.
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#TextFail stories from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@memersvg.
She says, "Tried to text
my photographer/foodie frien
'What if you were
a food photographer?'
but sent, 'What if you wer
a good photographer? 'instead.
This one's from @lisalou9399
She says, "My daughter texted me
about an award she got
in the Navy.
I accidentally replied
with the middle finger emoji
instead of the thumbs up."
-Wow, Mom.
-Wow.
This one's from @shoholajc
He says, "I once texted my mom
to send me a picture of my dad
Five days later,
I got a picture in the mail.
It's not worth it.
It's not even worth it.
-He didn't say "text me,"
he said "send me."
-This one's from
@sdbalasundaram.
She says, "My dad learned
you can abbreviate hate to 'H8,'
but didn't understand,
and started abbreviating
all the words with an 8.
Instead of 'love you,'
he writes 'L8 Y8.'"
[ Laughing ]
-L8 Y8!
-This one is from
@HannahEStrother.
She says, "My sister
accidentally texted her ex
that she wished
'nothing but the bed' for hi
and his new girlfriend."
That's nice.
Oh, this one's good.
This one from hannahpellicer
She says,
"I got this text from my mom
I don't know if she was trying
to tell me something,
or rap something."
It says, "As soon as you
get to Alabama,
as soon as you get to Alabama,
you need to go
need to go as soon
as you get there,
as soon as you get to Alabama,
unh, as soon as
you get to Alabama, unh!
As soon as you get to Alabama.
- [ Drums play ]
-Unh!
-As soon as you get to Alabama
-[ Band playing along ]
-Huh! As soon as you
get to Alabama.
-Unh!
-Go see bananarama.
[ Music stops ]
Go see Bananarama when I get..
are they on tour?
-Rappers love Banarama.
-They're on tour, yeah.
This one's from @LindsaySwink.
She says, "My sister was
texting a client who said,
'I'll meet you by
the bathrooms.'
She meant to write,
'okay, perfect,'
but instead wrote,
'okay, pervert.'"
"Oh, I didn't mean...
just meet by the bathroom.
-Not in the bathroom!
-This last one is from
the one and only Sheryl Crow
-Oh!
-She played the game!
We love Sheryl Crow.
Thank you for playing, Sheryl.
We love you.
Got a new record out,
by the way.
Sheryl says, "We taught my mom
how to use voice-text.
This is now
the family sign-off."
Look at this, it says,
"Karen and I just arrived.
Where in my room 720.
See you in a little bitch. Mom."
"Don't call me that, Mom!"
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags